[Musique]
non mais ils sont encore les mecs
je sais pas moi on m'a dit de la mettre
là la cabine
surtout que je suis pressé j'ai
rendez-vous
attention malheureusement vous allez
tous me décaler
c'est la carte j'ai une carte
moi je téléphone pas je sors ma voiture
c'est un parking ça y est mille voitures
là-dedans pourquoi ils m'ont dit de la
mettre là moi on nous fait sortir par là
pourquoi non mais là vous voyez pas
qu'il y a une cabine téléphonique
je vous laisse faire parce que moi je
veux pas que mon patron
allez-y allez-y allez-y
Léo
il y en a un autre
regarde-moi
[Musique]
attention le plexi monsieur non respect
non vous avez cassé attention attention
vous êtes en train de
d'embêter tout le monde avec votre
portable
encore encore encore
voilà comme ça c'est bon allô Roger tu
peux revenir là parce que il semblerait
qu'on ait mis la cabine où il fallait
pas ok on est là d'ici une heure une
heure une heure vous pouvez pas plus
vite parce qu'il y a un monsieur qui est
qui est coincé
à la police au gendarmes et vous êtes
complètement con hein alors vous voyez
pas que c'est la sortie d'un parking
il sort du parking il y a une cabine en
plein milieu c'est stupide mais pas la
mettre là ouais mais là il y a un poteau
on peut pas la mettre devant le poteau
pas sur la voiture malheureusement
c'est pas important
c'est pas un portable ça c'est
que cette fanfaronnade ça c'est de la
comme vous dites
ici je comprends pas c'est pas moi hein
merci Monsieur allez
quand même
vous êtes tellement sympathique
[Musique]